[Music]
[Applause]
alright man everyone seeing this I hey
man it's me and I'm ready I'm ready I'm
finally gonna do my Avengers review I've
been in New York I've been busy so I
haven't had a chance to do it but I've
thought about it a lot and I'm ready to
go
I normally when I'm in Los Angeles we
have office space at we work our office
the the SmartCall offices are in a we
work building so but when you have a we
work office space and it's a cool idea
it's like a bunch of you don't have to
have your own office building or office
space you share it with a bunch of the
cats when you do that no matter where
you go in the world you can enter into a
wee workspace so I came to a wee
workspace in New York down in Chelsea
look at this
this is work can you imagine like you
know what this reminds me of if you've
never seen nine-to-five like in the
third act of movie spoilers the ladies
like put together a way better working
environment and stuff that's what this
[ __ ] looks like it also looks like big
remember the movie big when Tom Hanks
was a little boy and became Tom Hanks
and then he at an apartment in New York
that looked like a little boy's
apartment that's what this is look how
fun this is man everyone's eat look at
that is that tacos tacos for may the
fourth what's your name Oscar ah here
man take a picture that wasn't planned
he's gonna take picture of him take
pictures I'll get my phone Morgan what
so explain today's made the Fords that
Wireless free food and see you tomorrow
more importantly right may the fourth
listen to me as true all right so
throughout this place if he got bunch of
200 people walking but it doesn't work
and doesn't look like work at all look
at them and they're all young everyone's
here I'm like the oldest person by about
25 years
look at these long ass work tables it's
fantastic and then you come over here
this is they got a bar look at them no
[ __ ] like first off look at this
spread of food oh my god but more
importantly look at look at the bar man
i'ma jump in real quick look at the taps
what kind of [ __ ] job is this all the
free coffee man it's just gorgeous hey
how are you guys
thank you look at the atrium like I
don't understand like [ __ ] this don't
feel like a job at all
I would be happy to come to work every
day I'm a bit they got one waiting for
me everyone thank you
everyone's friendly and it look at how
everyone works together and stuff like
but these are all this is these are
offices this is a modern version of the
office look at this stuff there's a
platform down there with couches
everything is like crazy homey man and
it creates like a working environment
where like you meet new people that have
nothing to do with your business and all
sudden you're sharing cool ideas this is
what is crazy man right over here this
big gas conference room that goes all
the way back
real nice sorry sorry you guys
everyone's enjoying their holiday food
man all right I'm almost where I gotta
go but this this is I like Mike can I go
in here thank you I like my we work
space in Los Angeles I'll be honest with
you this is the [ __ ] move man if this
was blue where I worked I'd come to work
every day all right mo get comfy cuz
we're talking Avengers man I'm ready for
this before we go any further spoilers
big time [ __ ] spoilers man spoilers
from Chelsea Chelsea down here in
Manhattan ladies and gentlemen this
thank you this we're talking about this
is Doctor Strange country down here man
this is we're down here is where the
sanctum sanctorum is so this is a good
place to do this review okay so the idea
is I'm gonna talk about the movie and
there's gonna be spoilers and stuff so
don't if you haven't seen Avengers
infinity Avenger Avengers : infinity war
yet [ __ ] off cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk real I'm gonna tell you real things
about it and stuff spoiler talk so if
you haven't seen it yet this video will
be around forever
come back when you've seen it everyone
left the room who's not a part of this
fantastic I
loved the Avengers infinity war it goes
without saying I'm in the bag for these
Marvel movies of course but this was a
stunning achievement this film was epic
epic in the way that old Hollywood
movies used to be epic like Gone with
the Wind and stuff like that and that's
tough to say in a digital age because in
the digital age it's really hard to get
that epic feel going because ever since
the Lord of the Rings movies we know
that like all those bodies man when you
see like all these bodies coming over a
hill a bunch of works and [ __ ] like that
ain't real as a bunch of persons in the
room with computers gone zeros and ones
eros ones and creating a look and it's
fascinating to look at but now the
audience is so trained for digital and
CGI that very little ever truly feels
epic not infinity war infinity war felt
large like the whole time I'm watching
the movie man I was like they spent a
couple hundred bucks like my god they've
they've they're back there they're gonna
they got to make at least ten thousand
dollars to get out of the hole on this
movie you could tell they put the money
up on the screen and also they did
something that very few people could
ever do man since they had a bunch of
movies basically telling singular
stories leading up to this big event you
could trust that the audience understood
things that were happening details about
characters and about relationships from
all the previous movies Kevin Feige the
great Kevin Feige god bless this [ __ ]
man my favorite person in the world
right now Kevin Feige had the good sense
man with ten years of Marvel movies to
train the audience and turn them all
into comic book readers when you're a
comic book reader as I used to be and
still AM to some degree and stuff like
that basically every month a new comic
will come out if you collected say
Batman or the Avengers or a spider-man
or every every month a comic comes out
new comic monthly then at the end of the
year they would have what they called an
annual which was a comic that told the
story that was kind of stand-alone
usually double sized issue and sometimes
that annual from that particular title
would tie into other annuals from other
titles and they do this
some crossover event across all the
titles and yeah I was kind of gimmick to
get your money and stuff but you were
into it particularly if the story was
was wonderful Secret Wars was one of
those stories from Marvel let's see 4 4
DC Armageddon mm I think was one of them
and stuff like that legends was one of
them as well of course crisis on
Infinite Earths so this this is a
concept very familiar to most comic book
readers comic book fans the notion of
like you know diving right into a story
because a everybody [ __ ] knows a
backstory here because they spent 10
years painstakingly making these Marvel
movies with care by the time you get to
to infinity war boom you launch in from
the first Frank from the firm that they
don't even do the music over the big
Marvel credit with the you know like
look at all the movies we made [ __ ]
look at our big fat Marvel dick as they
unfurl it at the beginning they were
playing dialogue from the adventure they
had so much story to [ __ ] tell that
they couldn't even let you hear that
music on the on the on the Marvel
Studios you know logo with the 10
lighten up which I [ __ ] love me my
nipples hard they were like we got too
much story to tell and bam right away
you start hearing a distress call and
remember like at the end of Thor
Ragnarok which we had such a good time
and then the Asgardians were saved and
stuff like you know there's that love PS
scene where the boys the brothers Loki
and Thor alike I think things are gonna
work out and then that giant ship shows
up literally like 10 minutes later or
[ __ ] an hour later when the Avengers
infinity war takes off is from there
starts with us finding the Asgardian
ship spoilers for Thor Ragnarok as well
with all the refugees destroyed with a
bunch of like dead bodies everywhere man
and we're meeting Thanos for the first
time in the movie now we've met him in
little pieces all throughout the Marvel
movies throughout the years guardians
the galaxy very memorable of course at
the end of the Avengers there's little
T's I remember when I watched that I was
like he looks like a big puppet but he
was CG they've set him up you know and
then there was the him grabbing the
gauntlet going fine I'll get up myself
but man oh man like they did
not let us know how deep and how well
rendered this character is going to be I
know fan oohs from the comics and my fan
osore the fan Oats that I know from
comics is the one that's like he wants
to kill half the universe to impress
death he was in love with death and he
was the mad Titan so he want to destroy
half the universe just to impress death
they didn't do that in this movie which
i'm i've thought was such a good idea
because they did something far better
they gave him motivation that made a lot
more sense like Fano she's just like
look whole [ __ ] world there's a lot
of people in this universe and very
limited resources man and so you know
the only way to save the universe is to
half the population and later on the
movie talks about one of the plans to do
two he's like you know what's happened
since then man kids never been hungry
and [ __ ] like that Christmas every day
he didn't say that but you know it's one
of those things where you're like man oh
man like that that's a reasonable and
maybe maybe it's not it's irrational but
it's a reasonable request of guy he's
trying to do something like the Avengers
he is also trying to do something to
save the world save the universe but his
is very extreme and nobody wants to try
that sort of thing
you know it's genocide you know that's
never the answer kids genocide is never
the answer
even though it seems sensible like when
Thanos lays it out you know because it's
not about race or it's not about I just
wanna hate down the world and I just
want to rule the world I just want to
like crack it in half
it's literally gotta go on like I just
think this is a smart play and it's
picking random so anybody could die
don't matter or who's ooh and so you see
they got a look at when he walked as you
see I'm in somebody else's office so I I
loved their presentation of Thanos I
love fan of cecile dronov his blade
approximate Knight so forth and so on
the the evany maw the introduction like
right there on the Asgardian ship when
you know Thanos is talking is Bill and
talk and then finally you know you hear
the whole like run from it you know it
comes in Here I am
Destiny's me and then you see him like
talking to Loki and Loki is asking where
the tesseract is he go
/ and picks up [ __ ] Thor and it's so
casual like you didn't realized Thor was
beating them on the ground behind then
he goes and picks them up and it shows
you the massive size of Thanos which is
one of the most impressive if not the
single most impressive motion captured
character I've ever seen I'm not taking
anything away from Andy Serkis and
Gollum and Planet of the Apes but like
you know they made this guy [ __ ] way
taller than a human being is with way
bigger hands and stuff like that and
they got all the subtle nuances of my
man's performance Josh Brolin did a
great [ __ ] job so at the end of the
day man it was like you know that you
got yourselves a character a bad guy
which Marvel is always getting like [ __ ]
on the people I got two bad guys they
need better motivation I don't
necessarily agree some of the bad guys
of course they're more well thought out
than others but like at the end of the
day this one in terms of having a big
bad for you know the be-all end-all in
terms of like oh [ __ ] this is a [ __ ] in
the end of the first few phases of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like I mean
think about it they didn't they don't
have Doctor Doom
they don't have Galactus there's some of
their big baddie names you know from the
history of [ __ ] comics they start
with Anacin Thanos is a well-known
character don't get me wrong jim Starlin
character and Infinity Gauntlet is very
respected series and books but you know
you ask your mom
you ever hear dr. doom of course dr.
doom she may not just go Fantastic Four
but she know dr. doom but if you tell
your mom two years ago or even last year
even ten minutes ago hey man you know
Thanos is you wouldn't know she'll never
forget once she sees this Avengers movie
it's incredible so right off the bat he
got a giant ass [ __ ] Thanos holding
for by his little pea head and
threatening to kill him and you know
remember I was talking to after Thor
Ragnarok I was like they are definitely
set and it was men wants to be in my
[ __ ] Instagram my facebook live look
at linger linger he I'm telling you man
like at the end of that flick you know I
was like they're gonna make Loki a good
guy they've been like his arc they've
been flipping him and [ __ ] yes he
attacked New York you know with Thanos
his army I said I guarantee you they're
flipping this guy's gonna make him
guy and I thought they'd let him die
heroically to save Thor but he doesn't
he just dies and the [ __ ] I mean does
try to save Thoreau first he's just like
I'm gonna fall kill him and [ __ ] then he
can't take he's like stop and so they I
was putting the [ __ ] gauntlet right
the Thor's head just charging his brain
up and should and so Loki
you know [ __ ] produces the tesseract
[ __ ] I was gonna say Darkseid
Thanos crushes the tesseract and inside
is one of the stones as it drops in the
glove and [ __ ] like that and what's his
name homeboy you know and this the order
may be a little juxtapose Loki you know
pulls a knife on Thanos like seriously
bro
weak weak Loki and tries to stab him in
the [ __ ] throat and Stannis has the
Infinity Gauntlet with a stone or two in
it which he got pre-show before the
movie began he went and stole one of
those stones from Xander so that means
that everything that happened in
guardians of galaxy remember John C
McKinley and he had the wife and the kid
and they were all happy at the end
you're like right on the Guardian saved
him and [ __ ] dead because they said he
wants his and are and stole the [ __ ]
stone and stuff so he he stops Loki and
then picks Loki up by the neck and
[ __ ] chokes him out and kills him
cracks his neck Loki dies like right in
the opening five minutes of Avengers
they kill him and [ __ ] and he doesn't
say he doesn't have a moment with Thor
Thor gets to talk to him and he says you
know make a statue with the Big Ben deal
ones like Matt Damon did I thought
they'd do that but they're better than I
am at Marvel they did something way
better so boom first scene and then
right there your love before Loki gets
killed man here's the cool thing
Loki you know is trying to give some
[ __ ] - [ __ ] Thanos and you know he's
just like we have a Hulk there's a
callback and awesome BAM Hulk comes out
of nowhere
[ __ ] banner cuz he was up in space if
he has guardians in Ragnarok and he goes
to fight Fano stars hit and I'm in [ __ ]
and the fan owes his children the you
know they were sitting there going like
she would do something the one guy's
like let him it was fun how many more
like let him have fun and so Hulk like
throw some shots and gets Thanos in a
corner and then Thanos starts fighting
back and he punches hope in the shoulder
and hope reacts like your friend when
you like you guys were Aslan or
something like that and we were punching
each other in the arm you punch Joe and
they're like oh man like that ain't cool
and he [ __ ] loses it like Hulk starts
to like whimpering oh then he gets his
ass [ __ ] beat which is a beautiful
sequence because you're sitting there
gone this guy Thanos who we don't really
know other than like little pig pieces
that we saw on the flicks previous just
[ __ ] handed the Hulk his fat green
ass and then oh my god what does that
mean so meanwhile before Logie gets
killed and hemdale is is there on the
floor and he's like you know he's the
guy who used to control the the Bifrost
with the giant sword and [ __ ] and so
he's just like oh my sweet Satan he
don't say that but he's just like give
me the magic power to [ __ ] send Hulk
home and he [ __ ] sends a beatin Hulk
who's gonna turn into Bruce Banner you
know - across like the gold across the
Golden Bridge of Asgard I somehow turn
to earth and you know fanless is like
you piece of [ __ ] and he [ __ ] kills
hemdale first man right in front Thorne
Thor's like you'll pay for that and then
he kills Loki and then he [ __ ] bust
the tesseract and he puts his were in
his glove and he's like what up I'm
gonna fist the universe [ __ ] and then
boom I think we're pretty much off and
running so first we spend some time what
with what's his name Doctor Strange
first we see like Doctor Strange going
to get a sandwich and Wong is this like
can you get me a sandwich that makes
jokes about rupees and [ __ ] like that
and then awesome boom Banner comes
[ __ ] soaring through the sky right
through the window of the sanctum
sanctorum right through the staircase
where if they were to monsters he would
have hit spot so you know all of a
sudden oh like he's laying down and he's
like fan OHS has come and Thanos is
coming then we cut to Tony and pepper
jogging in New York for the first time
Tony's got something in his chest that
we haven't seen in a while like a little
it looks like an arc reactor and you
know like what he took that out and
Avengers 3 what's going on and then you
find out that it's
something he's elected to put on to his
chest it's a he can take it off and you
know you find out what it is in a little
bit what happens is Doctor Strange opens
up a time you know opens up a [ __ ]
window in reality and he's just like
Tony Stark I am I'm dr. Stephen strange
and I need your help to save the
universe and [ __ ] and then he's like
what [ __ ] party magician and then
Bruce Banner comes out and he's like sup
Tony and he's like Bruce where you been
and pepper knows Bruce somehow as well
she said Bruce and then Tony decides to
go so where do they go next after that
man I guess at that point I know they
eventually go to sanctum and they start
[ __ ] bullshitting with each other
start talking to me like you know if
Phil Antonian on the back story about
Thanos this is something that Tony has
been thinking about for a long time it
was ha he was haunted by it from the
Avengers forward man they opened up a
hole in the sky blah blah blah so you
know he sees locking in go on [ __ ] this
is the dude and [ __ ] this is the problem
child this is the one I've been waiting
for and the interplay between Benedict
Cumberbatch and Robert Downey's juniors
superb wonderful man it's great to see
those two characters interacting and
it's just there but like those two
performers are real fun so boom boom all
sudden they start hearing some [ __ ]
people crazy outside and whatnot Thanos
sent his children to earth he's like
they're two Infinity stones on earth go
get him so you know you can even get
bother with earth he's gonna go stay on
Titan and [ __ ] he's gonna send his kids
to go pick that [ __ ] up so they they
were on earth and all of a sudden we see
outside the sanctum [ __ ] going on and
[ __ ] like the atmosphere is change
and people are running and [ __ ]
things are like a helicopter crashes and
[ __ ] like that
or maybe the helicopter crashes at the
end I think that happened p.m. so all
sudden you know Tony he's looking around
and heroes jump out on the street and
they look up and there's a giant
spaceship that circle spaceship Lord of
the ring and then they cut to Peter
Parker what uh spider-man on the bus
with Ned Leeds and he gets his arm hair
stained
and he [ __ ] says to Ned he's like I
need a distraction Ned doesn't even hear
him he just sees this he's like we're
all gonna [ __ ] die when he sees a
[ __ ]
Peter blasts out of the bus to go
[ __ ] help
what happens next show down in the
street man so have anymore
the mall meets our heroes and they're
trying to go after strange because he's
got in the eye of agamotto the one of
the stones I don't you know I'm not
going to pretend the time stone that one
I knew so there come for that [ __ ]
stone and then they have a kind of
showdown we get to see everybody Moss
powers and stuff like that and he'd
control like anything thrown trees and
ripping up pavement [ __ ] like that he
looks cool Tony calls him Squidward at
one point so you start finding Tony's
little chest thing it has nano bytes in
it nano by nanotechnology little robots
that turn into his [ __ ] suit so now
his suit just kind of covers him and
stuff no more no more pieces tiny pieces
so he has they fight Doctor Strange and
Wong opened up like Tom holes and stuff
so when when a man throws some [ __ ]
rocks at him they throw right back out
of me gets tagged and [ __ ] but he's
pretty powerful he looks it down on
everybody's got one of those voices and
she was like you will die like oh
alright Thanos so he Tony's keeps
telling Doctor Strange get the [ __ ] out
of here man if he's here for that
[ __ ] necklace like at one point he
says you know it's a Spider Man he's
just like there's a wizard they're
trying to steal a necklace from a wizard
it was very funny so uh Tony gets taken
out by what the big guy I don't know
what his name is man he's got this
big-ass hook and chain and [ __ ] knocks
Tony to [ __ ] down and stuff like cross
Washington Square Park I think it was
and then over Union Square and then just
as he's about to crush Tony you know
[ __ ] spider-man shows up and they've
got that cute relationship that they put
together in that other move
men and that Spider Man flick so
homecoming so it calls him mr. stark
it's adorable later on at one point in
the movie dr. strange goes this year
award like making a Robin Joe funny so
you know he's like what's the story and
he's like you know there's a wizard with
a necklace and they're trying to steal
it
and so spider-man gets involved in the
fight meanwhile let's see what else is
happening when that happens I know
Doctor Strange where Wong opens up a
whole time hole and that big ass guy
goes through it and it gets his hand cut
off and [ __ ] at one point so the ship
takes up ma have any more captures
Doctor Strange uses the pavement wraps
him up and [ __ ] and he's floating
through the [ __ ] City and
spider-man's like swinging and chasing
him and stuff and they get up to the
ship and the ships gonna take off but
you have Ironman chasing after
spider-man is up there as well he's
caught on but since it's going to the
outer atmosphere he's like okay I'm
breathe mr. stark
and Tony's like Vagan new suit new suit
and all of a sudden the [ __ ] new
spider-man suit that we saw at the end
of spider-man homecoming the iron armor
spider-man suit iron spider shoots out
of like Tony's [ __ ] lab or wherever
and then attaches to Peter and suddenly
he's got a suit just like Tony's now
with nanotech and stuff and it does way
more cool things and they need it
because he's going up the [ __ ] space
so him Tony Peter you know Parker and
Doctor Strange now in the spaceship but
Doctor Strange captured and stuff we're
gonna try to torture him to get the
deadlock seal whatever the [ __ ] it is
off the off the eye of agamotto
so that they keep the either the bad
guys could get the [ __ ] stone out of
it and give it to Thanos so that's
what's happening up there meanwhile down
below on earth let's see they go after
vision cuz vision you know of course an
Android and he's got the [ __ ] gem in
his head and stuff that's one of the
gems boom he gets [ __ ] attacked him
and the Scarlet Witch who are hooked up
I love that man because I was a big fan
of vision and Scarlet Witch miniseries
when I was a kid I stole it from a comic
book store not a comic book store a
five-and-dime that's sold
exhaust spinarak so I was like oh [ __ ]
they're there have their spending time
together having sex and stuff like that
they don't show it stuff but she got
herself a battery-operated boyfriend man
name a name a vision he got vision so
all of a sudden it's Proxima midnight
Corvus glaive show up an attack [ __ ]
vision in the Scarlet Witch and they're
trying to get the gem out of his head
the stone out of said and they fight him
off and you get to see the fall glory of
the scarlet witch's powers as she's like
you know [ __ ] protecting her man
taking him out of there and stuff so
Tony like when they were at the sanctum
they're like him and visions got that
stone said how do we find vision and
Tony's like you know we could call Steve
Rogers would know and him and Steve
Rogers ain't been talking since Civil
War but he's got that old ass cell phone
he's gonna go call him but then also
Thanos his kids showed up you know
[ __ ] outside so the phone goes down to
the ground but somebody else picked up
the phone and said i'ma call Steve
Rogers I think it was Bruce Banner if I
remember correctly so they wanna the you
know basically stories are starting here
starting here we're putting the teams
together the the Corvus glaive character
where do i where is it yes in the middle
of attacking vision and Scarlet Witch
there in Edinburgh Edinburgh Scotland
and they crash into a train station
because Europe is lots of train stations
and you know they're gonna get [ __ ]
corner and Proxima midnight is really
huge and so's Corvus glaive and stuff
they're supposed to be married in the
comics but I remember correctly and
they're you know about to tack them all
they're down for the count then all of a
sudden you know [ __ ] Proxima midnight
sees somebody as the trains go by in a
distance and it's that shot of our man
cat coming out of the darkness with a
[ __ ] beard looking like a bear man I
was at winked out for him I was like mmm
hairy cap I'm there for this
I said wolf that's what I said so he
comes out the darkness and he [ __ ]
you know the approximate midlife throws
are [ __ ] I'd catches it whips back then
all sudden a black black widow with
white hair shows up and she starts
[ __ ] fighting and then Falcon Sam
show
and he starts [ __ ] fighting and [ __ ]
and they stab Corvus glaive and she is
his wife so get up [ __ ] and he's like a
fact and [ __ ] and then she ports them
out of there she's like this is the
closer she'll ever come and killing us
[ __ ] and ports them out of there and
stuff like that so you know they're like
where we go what do we do and Steve's
like I got an idea
you know I know place week four first he
says let's go home so they go back to
Avengers mansion chef hood said that you
know not the mansion but the base that
Tony had built upstate New York and we
find out that like you know Hawkeye
ain't gonna be in the movie cuz family
and ant-man ain't gonna be in the movie
because ant-man and the wasp which the
trailer for it looks [ __ ] amazing
plus they've got like over 25 characters
to deal with man they could let let go
of those two so at this point the things
are starting to put into motion where
you're like oh [ __ ] like meanwhile
they're cutting up to space where Doctor
Strange is all you know [ __ ] tortured
being tortured by the mall and every
mall is like if I were to return without
the stone and David they put out blood
wasn't [ __ ] like that
and Doctor Strange won't let it go and
they notice Peter Parker of course is
played as the pop culture junkie that he
wasn't homecoming so he says to mr.
stark he's just like remember that old
movie aliens because they're on a
spaceship and so Tony shows up right
where Doctor Strange is getting tortured
and [ __ ] and heaven any mall is just
like I'm gonna [ __ ] smoke you two and
then he's like yeah but the kids seen
more movies and all of a sudden he
blasts the [ __ ] side of the spaceship
open and if I could have any more just
get sucked out and just like in
guardians he freezes in space and [ __ ]
then Tony
Ironman closes the [ __ ] hole again
and so boom they've saved Doctor Strange
but they're still like they don't can't
turn the ship around they're still on
their way to wherever the ships going
which turns out to be Titan
so that's what's going on with Tony
they're going to [ __ ] Thanos his
homeworld like Tony you know one point
dr. strange let's get the [ __ ] out of
here and Tony said well if we go home
with the eye of agamotto that's just
gonna bring people to earth and they
[ __ ] with us he's going the other thing
we could do is take the fight right to
him he's like you want to go to [ __ ] you
want to bring this this [ __ ] stone
right to him he's like see
he's not expecting at this point and you
know they don't say it but it's like
keep him off earth for Christ's sakes
Thanos you know doesn't doesn't the
whole time he ain't going earth that was
not his plan so we're seeing flashbacks
were spending time with Thanos as well
and the guardians the galaxy that's
right at one point we go to space and so
we see the guardians for the first time
since the movie they're all together
including mantis and they've gotten a
distress signal they're responding to a
distress signal sent by the Asgardians
and they show up and that's what
authority it's the windshield I'm sure
you saw that in the trailer
so then Thor meets the guardians of
galaxy and it's a really fun scene where
you know star-lord is just like he ain't
all that and everyone else is like this
guy's a [ __ ] godlike Drax is kind of
like crushing on Thor as well but Thor
and rocket hook up the best and so they
decide to go off to this place to build
a weapon quarters and have his hammer
hallow destroyed it and Ragnarok so he
said in order to kill thanos he's like I
gotta go get a weapon make this weapon
part of a dying star fires up [ __ ]
forms a weapon I gotta go there I don't
know the name never manera or whatever
[ __ ] and so rocket goes with him as does
a teenage Groot all he wants to do is
play video games an old asteroid or a
defender video game or something like
that from the Peter star Lords from like
the 80s probably in his backpack so they
go off and then the other Guardians stay
together and they're going to nowhere
where they had gone in guardians of the
galaxy the big giant Titan said that
people were mining out of and stuff like
that because they know there's a stone
being held there by the collector so
when they go off there they find nowhere
is like been ransacked and the [ __ ]
collectors getting the [ __ ] beat out of
them by Thanos and so apparently
somewhere in that scene if you look in
the background the collectors collection
they got a Tobias few K blue doubt you
know as a blue man in one of the cages I
didn't see it but I read that on the
internet which I thought was funny I did
see in the credits that it said
characters from Arrested Development
property Fox and I was like what
characters we all missed that so they're
guardians are hiding and [ __ ] like that
and Gamora you know had said to Peter
prior to that
she's like you know [ __ ] Thanos gets
me you got to kill me and he's like I'm
gonna do that she's like you got a
promise to be Peter you got to [ __ ]
kill me cuz I know something that
they'll make all the difference for this
guy and [ __ ] like if he finds out the
universe is [ __ ] so Peters like
alright I will they stay there or they
go to attack Thanos Gamora particularly
and Drax and stuff but Gamora kills him
like [ __ ] stabbed some years ago why
would you do that and then also at all
disappears and Thanos reveals that like
he'd used the gauntlet to create an
illusion he has the reality stone so
he's like reality's what I want it to be
[ __ ] and so he takes Gamora and
gets the [ __ ] out of Dodge and stuff
leaving the rest of the guardians there
and so those guardians are how do they
get from nowhere oh they go to Titan to
find [ __ ] Thanos so to find Gamora so
they go to Titan Tony and and Peter and
dr. strange on heaven Iman ship goes to
Titan as one crash lands on Titan so
when they crash land there they get
attacked by the guardians of the galaxy
and there's a bit of a scuffle and then
the funny exchange about like you know
I'm from Missouri he's like that's on
earth why are you being a dick and
attacking us and so fun interplay
between Tony and Peter as star-lord and
Iron Man meet and throughout the whole
[ __ ] movie there's these wonderful
meetings between characters that hadn't
met yet you know and it makes it just it
brings a comic book universe to life in
a way that like used to when I actually
read this [ __ ] on page all these people
know each other how cool and [ __ ] or
they're meeting for the first time or
they don't get along but they Wilkes
they're heroes they have a common goal
so that's what's happening on Titan
meanwhile Captain America is like you
know I know where we gotta go cuz the
vision got all [ __ ] up by his fight
and he's got stabbed like to to body and
[ __ ] like that it couldn't face so he's
like weak and dying and they're like I
know somebody who could fix him or we
got to go someplace and so they take him
to a condo we go back to well condo with
the black panther and shoot his sister
the princess you know is looking at
vision and trying to [ __ ] see if
where she could piece them together and
she's looking guys did it wrong and [ __ ]
I know like we're not as smart as you
so he's black panther's likes challahs
like can you fix him she's like yeah but
I need all the time I could get
meanwhile you know what Conda is about
to be under attack all sudden some [ __ ]
from space drops they got the shield so
like it hits the shield and [ __ ] like
nothing happens that what is they call
him the white wolf or you know I think
it was the wolf was his name Bucky you
know he's been laying low in Wakanda
getting fixed and so they pull him out
of retirement give him his arm back and
it's time for the Winter Soldier and
[ __ ] like that so they're they're about
to be under attack [ __ ] one of the
ships drops from the sky and hits the
shield just disintegrates and Bucky's
like I love this place Wakanda is
protected his [ __ ] then they go face
Proxima midnight on the other side of
like the shield wall and you know
they're like you know [ __ ] you what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do we're
on the other side of the shield wall
these ships drop out the sky and all
these [ __ ] animals you saw like
multiple arms could run and [ __ ] start
racing at the shield and just burn
burning themselves like trying to get
through it and cuts them in half and
they don't give a [ __ ] they're just
mindless animals and stuff but if you
start getting through and then they
start fighting our heroes and whatnot
there's a shot in the trailer that they
showed a bunch of euros running in the
jungle including Hulk [ __ ] oak
wasn't in that shot spoilers Hulk don't
show up again you know after you see him
in the beginning of the movie he fights
to stay in Banner and doesn't which
sounds dirtier than I meant it but he
don't come out ever against that lie was
told tour that that scene that's shot in
the trailer of them all running [ __ ]
I call it [ __ ] don't matter the
movies brilliant so their fight not
makanda like all the Avengers and what
not against the invaders and you know
one point Black Panther is like man
they're gonna go around the shield he's
like open the shield
so they opens shield so they you know
the fight comes in hard and thick and
fast and stuff so they're going at it
toe-to-toe man and meanwhile you know
the other storyline is Thor and the
as he calls rocket and Groot get to this
planet you know where all the weapons
are made including where mouling year
was forged and it's the forge is run by
a giant dwarf who was played by you know
our man Tyrion from Game of Thrones
and so but fana he had made the Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos and then Thanos said you
know [ __ ] you
your hands are mine and so he's got
these big like metal gloopy hands and
[ __ ] and the the whole place has been
shut down before everyone's killed in
the Forge fire is out so Thor's got to
restart it and he does that you know
like abusing his super strength and then
he's got to hold open the door so that
the [ __ ] light of the star dying star
could beam right through him into the
weapon so they can Forge and [ __ ] like
that
and after all this it's Stormbreaker the
[ __ ] big-ass axe battle axe and stuff
that's got groots
arm for an axe handle in a pretty metal
moment where group picks it up and pulls
it together there's a guy man cuts his
own [ __ ] hand off and [ __ ]
so at that point the thor is armed and
ready to [ __ ] go kill thanos and [ __ ]
so all of our stories of now are now
kind of coming together and whatnot
including in the Battle of Wakanda all
the sudden Thor shows up with [ __ ]
storm breaker and just starts taking
[ __ ] out man the battle turns and
[ __ ] meanwhile up on Titan Thanos meets
Tony Stark the Avengers and and the the
guardians of galaxy because Thanos at
one point he went off to this other
world man where you know Gamora knew
where one of the stones the soul stone
was so you know Anam pre before the
movie came out there's some some artwork
about the stones and the soul stone had
a picture of Iron Man taunts people were
like oh maybe the arc reactors the soul
stone turns out that's not the case at
all soul stone is in a place that is
guarded by the haunted and this was so
dope
so metal nobody told us this was coming
but as a fan of this movie I was
delighted that they called back to this
red skull red skull is in the scene
he's like his his damn job the job of
the Damned is to watch out you know for
this [ __ ] stone and he can never have
it himself remember he wanted he held on
to the tesseract and [ __ ]
in Captain America First Avenger and
then he disappeared that's where he went
he was a damn soul he looks [ __ ] damn
good man but it wasn't Hugo Weaving
playing it was somebody else I think his
voice was done by Richard Mark Brown
which i think is that guy who's on the
walking dead
in any event cool that he was there what
a nice touch what a nice like throw to
the fans of like you know whatever
wrapping a Red Skull there there's where
he is nothing good comes from bad guys
man bad plans and [ __ ] like that he's
telling Thanos he's just like if you
want to get the soul stone you got throw
something off this cliff that you love
who loves you and gomorrah's laughing at
his fat ass cuz she's just like nobody
[ __ ] loves you and you love nothing
and he starts crying and [ __ ] like that
she's like you cry and you crying and
then a red skull is like he's not crying
for himself you know and then [ __ ]
Thanos turns on Gamora who he actually
really likes the way they portrayed in
the movies he calls her his daughter
they show you the flashback scene how he
met her you know when he went to destroy
her world she was like a little lost kid
that he kind of took under his wing
turned him into the daughter but she you
know he took her he took her to us to
her sister nebula where she was all
[ __ ] up you know she'd mostly robotic
parts and Thanos was torturing her so
you know Gamora had to break down and
tell Thanos where the soul stone was so
there they are she's on the planet with
him and Pharaohs grabs her hand and
[ __ ] drags her to the edge she's all
crying and [ __ ] like that throws her off
so he had to destroy somebody love get
rid of something he loved trade
something he loved for the soul stone
and he traded gamora's life's really
[ __ ] heartbreaking and Peter had the
chance you know prior to that to kill
her like she said kill me and he went to
shoot her but fan OHS turned it into
bubbles coming from the guns so boom she
gets killed and he gets the [ __ ] soul
stone and he's all bummed about killing
her but he's almost there man he's just
like I can't let my I can't let you put
me off my mission I gave up my mission
once before I can't let anybody if I can
do this anymore and he throws her off
and he's got the soul stone so then
there's only one stone left to
get at that point and it's the the no
yeah well to he's got to get the stone
out of vision said Thanos and then he
has to get the time stone the eye of
from the eye of agamotto so how does he
do that let's see who does that in which
order first he gets the verse it's him
on Titan and it's the Avengers and the
Guardians versus Thanos and it's such an
incredible sequence to watch all these
heroes attacking him and him being
fought and held off from like being
mighty and [ __ ] like that
oh it's [ __ ] dope and then you know
at a certain point they gang up on
Thanos that was their beers Peters
plants to our Lord's plan and they're
all holding the piece of them and then
Doctor Strange opens up a hole in the
sky and [ __ ] mantis drops down lands
on Thanos and like you know does the
sleep thing and put some kind of under
which is such a nice touch of pulling
together all those elements from other
movies Marvel movies that we've seen
like the moment she grabs the moment she
drops and grabs as I said I'm sitting
there in the audience going yeah so
she's putting him and he's glossing over
and [ __ ] and you know she's an empath so
they're all struggling to get the
Infinity Gauntlet off his [ __ ] hand
Peter and iron man and [ __ ] like that
and tow you know Doctor Strange using
magic and [ __ ] and you know he's like
he's [ __ ] out but he's muttering and
[ __ ] like that and Peter's like we got
you piece of [ __ ] where's Gamora where
did you do with Gamora and like mantis
is like got her hands I said and she's
like he is feeling he's bereft like he's
sad he's [ __ ] not moving whatever the
word is when some of you said somebody
dies you know and and they're like why
why where's Gamora and [ __ ] like that
and finally it outs that he had to kill
Gamora to get the soul stone and Peter
goes apeshit you know he's a unit enough
to kill her and [ __ ] and you know Tony's
like you know stay cool mr. Lord he
calls him mr. Lord at one point star
Lori's like stay cool we almost got the
glove off them and [ __ ] Peter punches
peter star-lord punches you know [ __ ]
Tony
Tony Thanos in the face and it takes him
out wakes him up and he throws everybody
off and [ __ ] like that and starts beatin
ass and then you know Tony forms like a
[ __ ] like a sword
Leo fire sword laser sword you know from
his suit and goes at Thanos and [ __ ]
like that and vanos like grabs and stops
and breaks it off and then [ __ ] stabs
Tony with it and when I saw it in a
press screening in New York if that was
the moment that I [ __ ] screamed I was
like nah I was like Luke Skywalker
watching [ __ ] Bank Adobe get killed I
had a suspicion they were gonna try to
kill him or he might have gotten killed
but I wasn't emotionally ready for the
death of Tony Stark man that's how great
a performance Robert Downey jr. is give
him for 10 [ __ ] years I love that
character so much that I was verbally
distraught at the thought of him dying
but Doctor Strange at one point you know
on Titan was doing this [ __ ] he was
going through permutations of the future
the way what are you doing and he's just
like I've looked into the future 16
million possible endings to the scenario
and we lose and all of them you know and
they just like how many do we win he's
like just one so he's got you know
Thanos has them on the ropes and he's
beating the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] Tony if
Tony's Dionysus if you have to he's been
stabbed and Robert Downey jr.
performance is so good you believe like
this is it they're [ __ ] gonna let him
die right here on untighten and you know
he's given a speech Stano swears just
like I hope they remember you [ __ ] like
that it's cool when they meet at one
point he's like Stark and Iron Man's
like you know me and he's just like yes
I tuned Kirsten knowledge like it was
[ __ ] dope man that he knew who Tony
Stark's reputation precedes him into the
[ __ ] stars all was fantastic but
there is Tony dying and Doctor Strange
tells Thanos that he will give him the
the time stone from the eye of agamotto
and he's like no tricks wizard and he's
like no I'll [ __ ] do it
everyone's like God Tony's like down he
gives him the [ __ ] stone releases it
and stuff and he puts the stone in his
[ __ ] glove and then [ __ ] off and
[ __ ] so
Tony's like looking at doctors change
like how could you do dr. strange did to
save Tony's life but he said it was the
only way and I think that was in
reference to the 16 million ways in
which they lose in the one way they win
like dr. strange knew the only path to
victory is Thanos has to he has to get
all the stones been and he has to
[ __ ] do what he's going to do so
meanwhile Thanos then is like there's
one more stone again and it's the stone
and vision said and so you know vision
had told Scarlet Witch like you're the
only one with enough power in the
Avengers if if it comes to it you have
to [ __ ] kill me before he gets that
stone you have to destroy me Wanda and
she's like I don't wanna he's like you
gotta use she's a guy so they're all
makanda and the battles [ __ ] fierce
and stuff and then Thanos [ __ ] shows
up and you know he's like it's time
we're out of time
like you got to do it and Wanda's like
oh my god she starts killing her love
was just heartbreaking
so Harbor a what's-her-name Elizabeth
Olsen performance really [ __ ] great
they make her so tortured in those movie
she had to watch her brother die in one
movie and [ __ ] and she got in trouble
for blowing up people in the movie in
this movie they forced her to kill
vision she's like crying while she's
doing and stuff and he keeps going like
it's okay it's okay tells her he loves
her it's really sad
and then as Thanos is like trying to get
them and that's when you see that
sequence from the trailer which is
fantastic
Captain America fighting Thanos with a
nurse throws a [ __ ] punch and cat
catches the [ __ ] punch at Thanos is
like are you [ __ ] serious this mere
man there's a real nice moment on the
battlefield where you know this is what
happens is before we get there
feyo's is trying to get to vision and
Scarlet Witch Scarlet which destroys
vision and it breaks her [ __ ] heart
and stuff and you know [ __ ] Thanos is
like god dammit if only I had more time
whatever [ __ ] he's like in time is not
a problem for me [ __ ] and he just
Doctor Strange is the time backwards and
[ __ ] homeboy comes together again
vision and wanted to scream and like the
how and then [ __ ] Thanos picks him up
just plucks the [ __ ] gem out of his
head
in a really cool effect he [ __ ] dies
like all the vibrancy and color a vision
just goes instantly [ __ ] gray and he
hits the ground like a [ __ ] husk it's
really [ __ ] haunting and [ __ ]
so then BAM he drops it and he's got the
full [ __ ] glove and [ __ ] like that
and that's when all sudden out of
nowhere Thor shows up with storm breaker
and [ __ ] puts it right into that OSes
chests and [ __ ] like that he's a guy
haha and Thor is bearing in his chest
and it looks like oh [ __ ] like this is
the ending you know if it was a real
movie and not like the 10 year summation
of 19 other movies an epic it probably
would have ended right there with his
axe in the [ __ ] chest and Thor's you
know he's like I told you I'd kill you
and Thanos is like you should have went
for the head and then he [ __ ] shows
that his hand is free and as setup in
the movie you know Gamora says like he
used snap his fingers if he has all six
stones and the Infinity Gauntlet he
could snap his fingers and half the
universe would be decimated so he's just
like you should have went for the head
and then he snaps and I swear to God
very few movies ever been to in my life
affected an audience in the way it
affected not in spinel was there they
the audience like as as a whole
collectively gasped like it was [ __ ]
amazing man everyone was like you're
[ __ ] me we went on this journey and
that like he did it he did it and I cut
too danos like in this kind of dream
state with a little Gamora kid and she's
like to do it and he's like I did and
she's like what it cost and he's like
everything and then all of a sudden boom
were back in the world and Thor's like
what did you do and you see the gauntlet
is all [ __ ] up and [ __ ] because he
fanouts used it and even though he's got
the accident chest he opens up a hole in
[ __ ] it disappears through it and [ __ ]
like that gets away and all the heroes
so like what happened what happened and
then all of a sudden who was his name
[ __ ] a Winter Soldier Bucky is like
Steve and he starts disappearing starts
dissolving [ __ ] going away and [ __ ]
and everyone else like every other
person starts [ __ ]
dissolvent grouped dissolves and [ __ ]
like that and and Groot had a real nice
moment of Steve Rogers on the
battlefield where he's like I am Groot
and he goes I am Steve Rogers it was
very cool so in any event everyone
starts disappearing almost everyone like
Black Panther disappears
spider-man disappears in a really
poignant moment on Titan where he starts
the dissolving and [ __ ] like that and
he's like mr. stark and like you know
he's all and it is so sad it's like the
moment of every World War two movie with
the young platoon soldier on the ground
and [ __ ] and Tony's like [ __ ] wracked
with guilt he's like no and Peter's just
like I don't want to go like real sad
like a kid would be and then he [ __ ]
dissolves and [ __ ] like that and so they
like he snapped and they did it they
[ __ ] killed off half the goddamn
universe man you watched some of your
favorite heroes go only the original
Avengers lineup is still presented at
the end of it man and you know they cut
to a shot of Thanos and he said you know
they were like what happens when this is
done he's like with his done man I'll
wake up one morning you know on a grave
of a grateful world and [ __ ] my work
will be done [ __ ] so they show him like
limping over to the doorway and his work
done because he did what he wanted to do
he destroyed half the universe to save
it
and then they cut two [ __ ] credits
just says directed by the Russo brothers
like they did not [ __ ] around they
literally just like let's end the movie
Empire Strikes Back as [ __ ] let him snap
and take all these [ __ ] out man it
was crazy
dead silence in the theater as the
credits roll and nobody moved Grant said
we were in a savvy New York audience
with a lot of press and stuff but then I
saw an Iowa Des Moines like three four
days later or the general public same
thing nobody if I can moved what a
well-trained audience man after all
those years of watching those
post-credit scenes it's fantastic so
everyone sat and we all waited because
we're like there's no way there's not a
post-credits scene in this and then all
of a sudden
they cut to Tony Stark and Maria
I'm not Tony Sarg uh Maria Hill and Nick
Fury and you know all the sudden you
were sitting there going oh [ __ ] I just
realized Sam Jackson hasn't been in the
movie yet oh look they saved him for the
end piece and stuff and they're in a car
and they get hit by another car and they
look in the car and that person there's
no body there and then a helicopter goes
out of control presumably people are
disappearing as they were you know as we
saw in Wakanda and untighten and you
know Maria Hill is just like before that
happened she was like there's you know
disturbance over Wakanda you know and
stuff like that so all of a sudden
people start disappearing and Maria Hill
you know stay she's like sorry or
whatever and she's disappearing and then
Nick Fury immediately runs over to the
car news bag and he grabs this device
and his hand starts dissolving and he
goes [ __ ] and they dissolves to
help before I could say [ __ ] and the
device he was holding drops to the
ground I'm and I might [ __ ] cry doing
this because I screamed in the movie
theater so loud I was so happy about it
so the device there which is a pager
drops it down I push in you know on it
on the ground and it says sending and it
looks older [ __ ] like an old eighties
pager and [ __ ] and then finally it says
like sending sending and then a symbol
comes up and spoilers mmm it's so well
done these movies it's Captain Marvel
symbol now for those of you like so was
that mean and [ __ ] oh my god Captain
Marvel is gonna be Marvel's first female
superhero the driven film but Captain
Marvel is the one that will be able to
ride all these drunks the next two
movies that come out from Marvel before
the next Avengers movie Avengers four is
gonna be ant-man the wasp which is out
like two [ __ ] months the trailer
looks amazing but then after that is
going to be the Captain Marvel movie and
we're gonna meet Captain Marvel it's set
in the 80s and what Nick Fury was
younger so presumably at the end of that
movie you know before Captain Marvel
goes off in a space or some so [ __ ] you
know she gives him a [ __ ] pager and
says if you ever need me or he gives her
the device and says if I ever need you
I'm gonna get in touch with you and [ __ ]
so right before Nick disappeared out of
existence
he put
the emergency call-out to Captain Marvel
Captain Marvel is the most powerful hero
in the Marvel Universe so good oh my god
my only regret for the whole movie the
only thing I didn't like I was like you
sons of [ __ ] I gotta wait a [ __ ]
year a year but you know what we all our
movies coming out between now and then
including two really cool-looking
[ __ ] Marvel movies and ant-man the
wasp and and Captain Marvel that's gonna
set up you know what will happen in four
mannose Russo brothers they deserve a
special recognition Oscar if they want
to compete with everybody else fine but
they deserve like you know when they
give the Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
seven little Oscars
these [ __ ] deserve two gigantic
dick shaped Oscars for the stones the
Infinity stones on these boys the movie
they made it's so [ __ ] wonderful it's
so epic man I've seen it twice I'm going
back a third time to watch it within the
next [ __ ] week man I I dug it I
thought it was the achievement of a
dream you know when they made that first
Iron Man movie ten years ago this week
they came out they weren't sitting there
gone one day we will definitely get to
Thanos it was a dream [ __ ] like a dream
sitting there going like wouldn't be
great and they did it like after 10
years this is like watching friends
succeed at something you were rooting
for him so [ __ ] hardcore man like god
dammit they did it not only have they
made 19 utterly watchable movies but
[ __ ] they made this one movie to sum
all up in a giant-sized [ __ ] annual
type movie oh it's fantastic so there it
is man folks been asking me was your
vagan Avengers review I didn't want to
do it right away
because last time I reviewed a movie
right away people like you piece of [ __ ]
wait till I see it next time so I
figured it's almost a week if you
haven't seen the Avengers yet what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you how one American
if you haven't seen it go see it come
back watch this review four stars 26
thumbs up like honestly easily a top 3
Marvel movie if not a top 2 I'm a big
Iron Man fan the original Iron Man the
one that set the [ __ ] the spine of
the entire Marvel Universe but somebody
says they did nothing risky nothing
ballsy about killing off characters
everyone knows they'll be back
you don't know that I mean yes of course
this is safe to assume Black Panther and
Peter Parker did not die but there's
death there man and it's still ballsy
it's still [ __ ] big I'm sorry I know
some people like hey man if they'll come
back it was cheap
it wasn't it's a [ __ ] magic trick man
this is [ __ ] cool that's what movies
are about capture your imaginations [ __ ]
this one captured mine captured a lot of
people's imaginations and if you're one
of those people is like didn't capture
mine I feel [ __ ] ripped off well then
you know it's your prerogative but a man
I feel sorry for you you missed out on
something [ __ ] magical movie you
don't see a movie like that everyone's a
very very often it's [ __ ] huge man
like I watched that movie and I was like
I call myself a filmmaker what an idiot
so there it is man [ __ ] go see it
again if you're sitting there I'm on the
fence about this movie come on
who was it wolf Walt Flanagan I talked
to the guy from comic book men one of my
best friends in the world and you know
he runs Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash so I was like what did you think
of Avengers I got [ __ ] loved it you
know and Walter's not he doesn't go he's
not like me I'm an easy mark where I'm
like it wasn't in color I love it but he
was you know he doesn't always go for
everything Bay's I got [ __ ] loved it
and I was like what about that ending he
goes honestly he's gone the only thing
that I would have changed the movie may
be remotely better was when he sent that
message what came up was a number four
and I was like oh don't you hate that
when your friend writes a better version
of the movie that you already love and
[ __ ] goddamn it but you know what I'm
happy for Captain Marvel thing but yes
coming up by the time they're done with
Avengers 4 man we're into a world where
Disney or Marvel you know Marvel Studios
has the characters back that they've
never had before like x-men like the
Fantastic Four
thanks to this Fox deal so who knows
what happens for some people like
they're not gonna let all these people
die maybe they do because they got a lot
more characters to come off the bench I
love this movie I cried twice at least
during the flick and screamed multiple
times I was so like loud I got in Los
Angeles people get very loud at the
movies and stuff in New York not so much
and we were in New York screening and I
was
now and yeah [ __ ] like that there's a
little kid sitting across from me
he saw me getting into it and being
vocal and he got vocal too about things
he'd be like yes yo look over at me to
be like this is cool we're not gonna get
thrown out it's kind of movie that makes
you yell out loud man what a great
audience watching experience I had
watching this play there it is that's my
review for those of people that are like
oh my god
Disney pay some money I have [ __ ]
wish that they would give me money to
blow the Avengers but I just I just like
the movie can it just be that a guy
likes the movie [ __ ] man that's it it's
just fandom folks I'm a I'm a 47 year
old man but I'm watching movies I never
thought I'd see in my entire life and
and they're they're crushing them so I
like a man I can't help it I make no
apologies thanks for hanging out was a
really long review we work folks look at
this world behind us I'm gonna go out
and get some [ __ ] they had some vegan
food out there for those of us that you
know can enjoy an animal food product
and stuff thanks for hanging out I'm
coming to Cal Canada next week Calgary
Edmonton Winnipeg Vancouver if you're
around come see me do shows with Jason
Mewes or Ralph Garman there it is man
that's my Avengers infinity war review
from we work here in Chelsea the home of
dr. strange there's Kevin Smith man
thanks for looking at 59 minutes what a
fool I am thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you